- I'm gonna mess this up, my bad.
@HakunaFatumata wrote,
and I'm really sorry if I messed that up,
"My crush only uses
Instagram to message with me,
he sends heart eyes emojis to me.
He hasn't asked for my number.
How do I convince him
to take our relationship
to the next level and actually text?"
Ooh, I have advice.
I don't know if you want it.
Okay Marlon, why don't you start.
- First of all,
why are you yelling at
us with your text, girl?
Why are you doing all caps?
Get some lower case in there.
(laughing)
You know, I'm old fashioned.
I think a man should court you
and if he, if he's serious, then he'll,
you know, ask you on a date
and he'll take you on a nice date
and he'll, he'll chase you.
Play hard to get and see, watch him chase
and if he don't chase, let him go.
You're the gift, not him.
(audience cheering)
- Oh my gosh, I love you.
Okay, speak on it.
Go ahead Cleo.
- You know,
I think dating is kind of like
also when you're looking for any job
or thing you want in life,
you know, you have to
be unafraid to lose it
because then when you, if you do have it,
you know it's yours
and you can also just create boundaries
that help you do that if
you're not used to being,
you know, strong enough to
like stay away from your crush.
So I mean, if it was
one of my girlfriends,
I'd probably be like,
well, take Instagram off
your phone for a week
and tell him you're doing it,
so that if he wants to
get in touch with you
he can text you.
And if he wants to text you
or if he actually is
interested in you in that way,
then you'll know by then
and if he doesn't,
you have to be unafraid to keep it moving.
- Ooh, you got games.
(laughing)
- I do.
- I love you.
And my thing is, I don't,
I don't understand why you'd
want to be with someone
that only does it in front of people.
That's my thing.
Like if they're only gonna show you,
they care in front of people,
you want, you need to
know what's happening
behind closed doors,
not in front of the doors
'cause that's who you're gon' be with.
Just so you know
and it kind of looks a little
like He's Just Not That Into You,
that book, I don't know.
It looks a little like that.
Like, and that's okay
'cause we've all been there, kay.
So it's not just you.